Howdy folks. My throat is feeling better enough
to record a youtube video, so here I am. I plan
to upload weekly for the next month to clear
out the backlog of videos I’ve been working on,
so hopefully that can fill the deep hole
in your heart that I’m all but certain my
absence has wrought. I also have a big video
about manabases coming up later this month,
and with that in mind I figure I may as well
run back through a subject that is near and dear
to my heart—land counts. Now, I did talk about
this a bit in my lands video almost a year ago,
but there was a bunch of other stuff in that video
and my thinking has developed a bit since then,
so I figure this video can serve as a more
targeted guide. The question I’ll be looking
to help you answer in this video is “how many
lands should my deck have in it,” and perhaps
more specifically, “should my deck have more
lands in it?” To help me out with answering
this question I’ll be using a deck I built
in March of last year—my Radha battlecruiser
deck. You can watch the video about it if you
want, but the relevant information for this
video is that it is a deck with a mana dork
commander, a pile of four mana ramp spells,
and a bunch of 6 and 7 drops filling out the
rest of the deck, resulting in this deranged mana
curve. It also runs 41 lands. A bunch of people
have made decks riffing off this deck, which is
super cool! I always love to see my decks being
an inspiration for people. What I’ve also noticed,
though, is that a common first change for people
is cutting 3-4 lands from the deck. I guess people
must assume that I pulled the number 41 out of a
hat, or maybe that’s just my cute little personal
preference. I know I’ve frequently seen land
counts referenced online as an across-the-board
preference of sorts for people, like you’ll see
people say that they prefer 35 lands or 36 lands,
or that they’re a 38 land sort of person, and
other such statements. I suppose maybe people
consider setting the land count of a deck they’re
adapting to their preferred number as a part of
putting their own spin on it. Maybe. I’ve also
seen people react with shock or skepticism when
I mention that one of my decks has a land count
in the 40s, so maybe people just aren’t sold on
a count that high. Regardless, I want to discuss
the different factors that should influence land
count, discussing how each of them applied to
this deck as an example, and at the end of that
process maybe it’ll be a bit more clear why I went
with the number I went with, and you might have a
bit more insight on how many lands might be right
for your deck based on its particular attributes.
For starters, let’s talk about mana curve—mana
curve refers to the mana costs of different
cards in a deck, and on the most basic level the
average mana cost of a deck is an indicator of
how much mana that deck needs to do what it wants
to do. As a general pattern, lower curved decks
will want less mana than higher curved decks, and
will thus also want a lower land count than higher
curved decks. However, in the context of commander
this is more of a correlation than a rule,
and there are two main factors that contribute
to this correlation. One of these factors is how
quickly a deck is looking to win the game, with
lower curved decks typically winning earlier
than higher-curved decks. Power level and how
proactive a deck is will both affect how quickly a
deck looks to be closing out games, but regardless
this land-count-vs-win-speed pattern tends to be a
reasonably consistent one to see. Put simply, you
don’t need to play a land on turn 7 if there is no
turn 7. Another way that mana curve can influence
the number of lands a deck wants is in terms of
how accessible the deck’s ways to dig for more
lands are. A deck with lots of low-cost draw and
filtering can afford to run a lower land count
as long as it can find the colors to cast those
digging cards, whereas decks that feature draw and
filtering that costs four or more mana will want
to run a higher count in order to consistently
get enough mana to pay for that draw or filtering,
or at least supplement with ramp. Likewise,
decks whose source of dig is more complex,
such as a deck that needs both a Garruk’s
Uprising and some big creatures to trigger it,
will want to be careful to run enough
lands to avoid getting stalled out on
mana before getting the chance to fulfill
the condition that will draw them into more.
Most of my reasoning so far has been in terms
of how low a count a deck can afford to run,
but it’s also useful to think about the question
of mana curve in terms of how high a count a deck
can afford to run. More complex or mana-expensive
forms of draw also typically draw more cards,
and if a deck has a lot of heavy duty draw—such
as a green deck running a number of cards that
draw cards equal to a creature’s power—it can be
possible to run quite high land counts without
really feeling negative impacts from it. What
happens if you draw 10 cards and then end the turn
with a hand containing six lands and 8 nonland
cards? You discard four or five lands, that’s
what. When a deck can readily access powerful draw
that is a bit mana expensive, running a higher
land count is often an all-around win—either you
haven’t gotten enough mana to play the draw yet,
in which case a high land count helps you have a
higher chance of getting there, or you have played
the draw, in which case you’re churning through
enough cards to render that slightly increased
land density negligible. What this relates to,
really, is how good a deck is at spending its
mana. Let’s think about what we’re worried about
when adding more lands to a deck—it’s flooding
right? We’re worried that we’ll draw a bunch of
lands, and instead of having cool, impactful plays
to make, we’ll be stuck sitting around with a
hand full of lands. This is a valid concern,
and *one* way to mitigate it is to run fewer
lands, but another way is to make sure your deck
is consistently able to churn through excesses
of mana. Having a higher curve alone will provide
some insulation against getting flooded, since
playing a six drop is twice as card-efficient as
playing two three-drops. This doesn’t necessarily
mean that you should pump up your curve to avoid
getting flooded, but it does mean that drawing
a lot of lands will be more problematic for some
decks than others. As far as tools reduce flooding
go, the sort of big draw I mentioned earlier is
a fantastic way to improve a deck’s ability to
spend mana, and there are a few different options
here—decks can run a lot of it, decks can run less
of it and run filtering or tutors to find their
way to it, and decks can also just put it in the
command zone. There are also other ways to improve
ability to spend mana—MDFCs can be nice nonland
plays if a land isn’t needed, and there are also
impactful mana-sinks like X costs and multi-use
activated abilities. Utility lands can be another
great way to avoid running out of gas as long as
their abilities are relevant to a deck’s goals.
So, to pivot over to our example for this video,
how does my Radha deck do on these criteria that
I’ve mentioned? In terms of mana-curve, it
has a horrendously high average nonland card
cost of 5.33, and nothing below 4 mana in the
99. Its cheapest ways to dig for additional
mana are some draw effects at 4 mana that require
additional game actions to actually begin drawing,
and I guess some cascade cards on five mana? You
could say that the deck’s ramp helps it out in
terms of getting lands, but this deck would
much rather ramp and hit its land drops—each
land is effectively worth two mana, meaning that
every land drop that the deck needs to ramp out
rather than playing normally bears an expensive
opportunity cost. I bumped the land count from 40
up to 41 specifically because I had too many games
where I was having precisely this experience,
effectively paying mana for land drops that I
could be making normally. Okay, so high-curved
and a high-threshold to dig for more lands—these
features tell me that a low land count would be
tricky to pull off with this deck. But what
about its ability to spend mana in effective
ways? For one, the high curve alone gives the
deck a nice boost in maintaining cards in hand.
It just can’t play cards very fast early in
the game, so its hand size stays big for a
while into the game even as it’s spending similar
amounts of mana per turn as the rest of the table,
and sometimes more. In addition, though the
number of draw spells in this deck isn’t wildly
high—like 9 or 10 if I’m being generous about
what I consider draw—the deck is sees a ton of
cards due to the amount of cascade in it, and
the fact that several of the draw spells cost 4
mana means that they pop up reasonably often
due to the nature of the mechanic. Finally,
I play a handful of mana sinks such as Captivating
Crew for the situations when the deck has an
absurd amount of mana but is low on places to
put it, and I also have a Panglacial Wurm for
when I topdeck a ramp spell and would quite like a
wurm to go along with it. With all of these tools
for spending mana, I rarely feel flooded with
this deck even though the deck runs 41 lands.
So, that covers the biggest factors
that influence a deck’s land count,
but let’s talk about a handful of others that can
also come into play in certain decks. For one,
the power of mulligans. You can watch my mulligan
video if you want a full rundown of this topic,
but the basic gist goes something like
this: depending on how they’re built,
decks will use their mulligans to find some things
more than others. Some decks will be prioritizing
having a piece of ramp in their starting hand,
some will prioritize a synergy piece to go with
their commander, some will prioritize a low-cost
creature, and some prioritize having 3 or more
lands. In a probabilistic sense, this is kind
of a zero-sum activity—you can only use your
mulligans to hunt for so many things, and if you
stretch yourself thin on this front you might find
yourself dropping down to 5 card hands more often
than you’d like. What’s good to keep in mind,
then, is that running a land count closer to your
ideal land proportion in your opening hand gives
you more wiggle room to use your mulligans
to hunt for nonland cards, and 42 is the
number of lands in deck that offers the highest
chance for a 3 land hand. My Radha deck wants a
piece of ramp every game without exception,
a fairly stringent goal for nonland cards,
so running a land count close to this 3 land
proportion means more 3-4 land hands and more
ability to aggressively mulligan for ramp. Your
deck may be more flexible in what nonland cards
it wants in its starting hand, in which case a
lower land density and a focus on mulliganing
for lands may be a more worthwhile plan,
but it’s good to consider the tradeoffs.
Another reason somebody might want to run
a higher land count is that it can allow a
deck to have extra lands in hand more of
the time. An obvious application of this
is extra land play cards—these are often some
of the most efficient ramp spells out there,
but being able to take full advantage of
them requires running a land count high
enough to have extra lands on hand. A less
obvious application is that a higher land
count gives a player greater control on the
timing of when certain lands are played. A
32 land deck will often need to play a Bojuka
Bog on curve in order to not miss a land drop,
and this might end up greatly reducing the
effectiveness of the card’s ETB. The same
goes for Mystic Sanctuary, Mortuary Mire, and
Talon Gates of Madara—getting substantial utility
out of these lands without missing a land
drop gets easier the more lands a deck runs.
Finally, let’s talk about one reason some decks
might want fewer lands. Some decks care about
what’s on top of their deck more than others,
an attribute that I like to call The Cantrip
Coefficient. An example of a deck with a higher
Cantrip Coefficient would be a conventional build
of a commander such as Jhoira, Weatherlight
Captain. Most Jhoira decks run lots of low
cost artifacts, often alongside cost-reducers,
and then seek to cast a ton of artifact spells
in a single turn. This is a playstyle that
draws lots of cards one at a time and wants
drawn cards to be either an artifact or
an artifact payoff card, and as a result
these decks will generally want to run as few
lands as they can get away with. Storm decks,
as many Jhoira decks might be considered,
care more about the top of their library
than just about any other type of deck, and will
thus usually try to run a very low land count. A
lot of enchantress and spellslinger decks will
also rank highly on the cantrip coefficient,
wanting to run as many of their respective card
types as possible. Even my Sharuum Slide deck
could fit into this mold to some extent with
its relationship with cycling cards, though the
existence of cycling lands and landcycling cards
makes its relationship with lands quite different
than these other decks. The biggest factor here
is that these are high-velocity decks, decks that
churn through cards at a fast rate, and also decks
that run lots of low cost cards. On the other end
of things you’ve got decks with larger-scale
draw, particularly ones that also have lots of
high-cost cards. My Radha deck is more on this
end of things—it runs a couple cards that draw
cards one at a time like Beast Whisperer and
Soul of the Harvest, but outside of topdeck
situations with these in play it doesn’t care
too much about what percentage of lands it draws.
So, that’s how I came to the land count in this
particular deck. Very high average mana cost,
high threshold to access draw, strong ability to
spend mana and maintain cards in hand, and a need
to mulligan aggressively for ramp rather than for
lands. You can follow a process for this, like I
did in this video, and I’m showing a checklist on
screen right now that you can screenshot if you
like, though this is a rather crude summary that
shouldn’t be treated as gospel for every deck. I
should also note that though I position 35-37 as
a moderate count, with the number of MDFCs and
utility lands we have these days I’d guess that
the median casual EDH deck would actually be best
served by a land count of somewhere around 38.
You can even use a formula like that suggested by
Frank Karsten if you really want to be handed
an exact number. However, both that and the
guidelines I’ve suggested can only give an initial
estimate, and after that it’s a matter of testing.
When playing a deck, try to keep track: how
often are you finding yourself wishing you
had a land to play, and how often are you finding
yourself wishing you had a nonland card to play?
Importantly, pay attention to lesser cases
of these, not just the mega-floods and the
mega-screws—I’ve seen players consistently
miss land drops over the course of several
games before hitting a 1 in 20 game flood and
taking it as a cue to cut lands. If both land
shortages and nonland shortages are happening, is
it possible to inject some additional ways to keep
cards in hand into the deck rather than cutting
lands? Cut out deadweight cards that aren’t
improving your deck’s ability to maintain a fluid
gameplan to give you more space to work with,
or replace some combination of ramp, draw, and
removal with versions that are more concentrated
if you can afford to without making your deck too
clunky. Adding an MDFC or a utility land can also
be a great way to improve the feel of your deck’s
card/mana balance, to allow the deck to hit the
same number of land drops but have more ways to
spend mana, or give an additional land drop while
maintaining that slot as a way to spend mana,
depending on what’s being cut. Modern Horizons
III had both a lot of great MDFCs and a cycle of
pretty lovely utility lands, and in the post-MH3
EDH landscape I truly don’t understand people
who are clinging onto low-mid-30s land counts for
their conventionally-curved midrange EDH decks.
Add lands! They let you cast spells! There’s also
the question of how to navigate colors in your
lands, but that’s a question for another day.
Thanks for watching! And thanks
to Archidekt for supporting the
channel. Remember how I mentioned how land
counts affect mulligans? With Archidekt,
there’s a hypergeometric calculator a short scroll
away that can give you an immediate sense of how
likely you are to draw various numbers of
different card types. Pretty dang cool,
if you ask me. I’d also like to thank my lovely
patrons, who are on-screen now. I just opened
submissions for my deck review for this month, so
if you want a chance to get your deck reviewed by
me, you can sign up for my patreon today
for three bucks a month! Alright, bye.